There's no one coming for you and saying,
by the way,
did you know you were entitled to this?
There's no way?
When my employer wanted to fire me,
he thought that I didn't know the different types of dismissal
and that the way he wanted to fire me,
it fit into the economic dismissal So he called me and he said,
look,
we're going to delete your position,
I say to him very well,
what do you offer me?
And there he proposes me 1 conventional rupture and I say
well no if it is 1 suppression of job,
it is 1 economic dismissal And in fact that's the problem today,
if you don't know the law,
it's not your employer who will teach you how it
works Whether it is in the business,
in the employee or in the everyday life,
it's up to you to go get the information,
it's up to you to inform yourself Know your rights.